very very rarely this somebody keep
winning over and over again what if the
mind said after you win the first one
insanity madness we're talking about how
you look without your clothes on it's
like your worst nightmare turned alive I
thought wow like this guy is bigger than
the Incredible Hulk if I could look a
little bit like that you know I'd be so
happy upon that night I realized well
I'm gonna win this damn thing about God
I'm motivated I'm ready to kick some ass
I'm doing promos I'm telling everybody
I'm coming for you I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna do that I didn't deserve to win
very interesting he looked at me and he
knew that I wasn't messing around we
respect the champion pissed him off
to the point where we barely even talk
anymore okay Phil is the easiest guy to
interview I guess one question we went
for 30 minutes very easy no Christmas
cops in the house and someone robbed us
one of my friends brothers got shot in
the face extends for my life flash
before my eyes every Y in the road
winning state in basketball getting my
degree all those little things from the
heartbreak to the lies to the deceit
from others from the mistakes I made to
this and that got me here I'm a passive
all player right you damn right I'm
happy it's just been a wild journey
[Music]
in the world of bodybuilding there's
only been a couple people that have won
mr. Olympia seven years in a row and
he's one of them everybody around the
world
male guys grow up on each other muscles
they look at people like him this
nickname is the gift because if we've
never seen a body like his his body is
so unique on how we built his body to
the point where he was seven mistral
appears consecutively and one thing most
people don't know about it was the
following he got a degree from Denver he
played basketball for college and he
majored in accounting some people see
muscle like he must not be that smart he
majored in accounting finance that's
what his major was before he got into
bodybuilding give it up to seven times
showing up here
[Music]
arrived
so so first of all before we get into it
how is this event been for you everybody
coming up to you talking to business all
that it's been incredible it's a lot
different sitting up here because I've
been sitting over there this whole week
with you guys how are you guys doing you
guys doing good all right I do want to
say thank you all but obviously you
think you Pat being here has been an
incredible experience for me and I'm
sure it has been for all of you this is
a much different type of conference that
I normally attend but I can tell you
this one of the greatest ones of my life
and I know I speak for a lot of you when
I say them thank you thank you thank you
can say that yeah so you know you're not
set down before we've talked about a lot
of Astral and view those kinds of things
the part I want to talk to you about is
very very rarely this somebody keep
winning over and over and over and over
and over and over and over again that's
seven times
very rarely right we respect the
champion right you know somebody wins
the championship 1 time they're like
listen respect forever yes
somebody visit two times in a row much
respect three three-peat
seven Pete's Celtics no one in the NBA
in seven seven times in bodybuilding
it's only two people that ever done it
before so what if first off what is the
mindset behind you wanting to do that
consecutively and not getting tired
after you win the first one insanity I
guess I don't know madness like you
talked about you know when I got into
the sport of bodybuilding it was on
October 8th 2002 I just completed my
last season at the University of Denver
playing on the men's basketball team
during that summer I you know I was
thinking about maybe trying to play
overseas stuff like that then I kind of
realized fill your 5 9 180 pounds
probably not going to work so then I
started you know hanging out with some
bodybuilders on campus and thought you
know what maybe I'll try this I just you
know I think I have the physique to try
as an amateur and ten years you know I
want to say that first ten years was
pretty incredible because you know I had
to learn a lot about myself and a lot of
the talks that you've had up here I did
get kind of emotional at times because
when you're really going to the core of
who you are not a lot of people ask
yourself that question I would even ask
you guys how many of you this morning
looked at yourself in the mirror after
you brush your teeth wash your face like
really look at yourself in the mirror I
mean for me I always try to do that and
bodybuilding initially made me have to
look at Who I am as an individual do I
want to do the training okay fine I can
train but do I really want to diet do I
really want to give up time with friends
do I want to be misunderstood am i okay
with scrutiny because unlike a LeBron
James or Kobe Bryant I was taught it's
just that over here about it unlike
anything else you could be criticized
about performance in the office how you
speak how you may be how you dressed
that day or whatever you didn't close a
deal we're talking about how you look
without your clothes on you know a lot
of people in here maybe switch outfits
you talk to my fiance I mean she
probably changes three four times
sometimes you know did this look good
this is good because you know they want
to be perfect it's a good point but
imagine your job is to be judged by a
panel of judges fans around the world
about how you look in just this little
itty bitty posing trunks it's like your
worst nightmare turn to live I knew
early on that I really wanted to just
have another outlet other than
basketball I wanted to be able to
transfer those attributes that got me to
play Division one level to something
else and I knew that I didn't have to
put my teammates on my back to get the
job done this was all about my effort my
effort alone I had to learn a lot
had to spend a lot of time reading about
we didn't have the resources that we do
now with the internet you know flex
magazine muslin price right all these
old books the Nautilus books and all
this other stuff you know how to train
watch it and pump an iron on VHS how
many times have you seen that countless
times that I've probably purchased it
three times like literally the VHS would
you know you know how it works I mean
eventually it's done and then a couple
hundred times well at least you know at
least because you really wanted to
understand the history of the sport who
was the man at the time you talked about
Aaron Swartz nagger
we all know who he was for who he is and
definitely somebody that I admired early
on to to be a champion you know like he
was definitely one of my childhood
heroes because at the time you know
growing up we had the President's
Council of Health a fitness test and he
was the guy that was conducting that I
thought wow like this guy's muscular
like this guy's bigger than Lou Ferrigno
like The Incredible Hulk like he's
shaped in Adonis fashion that if I could
look a little bit like that I you know
I'd be so happy little did I realize
that be a lot bigger than that and it
has just been a wild journey how did you
mentally like when the stomach gets full
you're like I've won again I won again
I won again I won again how does that
keep you focused to keep wanting to come
back and win because sometimes you know
success is the biggest liar right
because it gives a lot of blind spots
how did you consecutively stay hungry
that's the biggest challenge sometimes
in business you make a lot of money you
make three million in a year yeah you
know like what do I come back again next
year what what record am I trying to
break this year you know when I did my
first mission Olympia contest it was in
2008 I had turned pro in 2005 so I was
like okay I'm kind of like a LeBron or a
little Kobe Bryant coming out high
school sponsorships everything everybody
attentions on you I qualified for the
Olympia in 2006 and 2007 declined to
compete because I felt like I needed
more experience pissed the hell out of
Joe Weider I mean he was our Godfather
building he was my boss for flex
magazine muscle fitness I had to sit in
his office and tell him no I need more
time are you talking about Phil like you
could be top three no I need more time
but I'll make it count so I placed third
at my first mr. Olympia contest in 2008
upon that night I realized it's possible
but but when and at first you say we'll
win okay I did third third in the world
well now it's not about win it's about
you know how many so when I got that
opportunity and if I and if I may I'd
like to tell you a quick story about
this so in 2008 I placed third that
following year I'm thinking well I'm
gonna win this damn thing you know it's
my first time I got third I'm about to
go ahead and beat these guys I got food
poisoning the night before and we talked
about things that you can't control I
trained I did the diet I did all that
stuff sometimes when you're dieting the
way that we diet your immune system is
very very compromised the slightest
thing handling a food fish steak stuff
like that it can really mess with you
shaking hands with fans the night before
could do that
you just never know it's almost like
someone getting up and saying how you
doing Phil what's going on it's like
sweaty hand this mat next thing you know
you're touching your face on accident
next thing you get sick you get people
from all over the world coming soon
Olympia so I don't know what it was but
I just remember having the EMTs come
into my room at 5:30 in the morning that
Friday and they're telling me not to
compete and I say you know what let me
give me a second okay God you know
what's going on I can't control this
they want me to go to the hospital I'm
not going in hospital but if I throw it
one more time I'll go but I don't want
to go because these fans I just met from
all over the world paid a lot of money
to see me so if I can just compete I
know I'm not going man but if I can just
compete I'll be all right so I placed
fifth at that contest and I you know I
was really disappointed because you know
you go from third to fifth
you know and
one of the defining moments in my life
at that time was the following day we
had a photo shoot with Joe Weider and
anyone had ever read a flex magazine
especially with Arnold Schwarzenegger
Joe Weider was always there always there
well as he got older he's no longer with
us as of today but that was the last
photo shoot that he would have with all
of the athletes and it was the first
time since those days of Arnold that
flex magazine athletes muscular
development athletes which was a rival
magazine still is all came together so
it almost be like DC and Marvel coming
together for Stanley and having a photo
so that's kind of like what it was I was
there two hours before the photo shoot
reporters come in they're like why are
you here I'm training legs now I just
lost 26 pounds competed this and that in
the other and I'm talking about 26
pounds in one day and competed while
everybody else is you know partying it
up Saturday you know whether they won or
lost you know they're all having a good
time eating pizza doing this I'm
thinking about how I'm gonna get better
I said you know what I'm gonna get my
ass up I'm gonna go to the gym now I go
to the gym reporters are like why are
you here and why are you trying to
ladies of all things or to plead it
you're this and I said I got v last
night they're like yeah but you you know
you got sick you know it happens this
you know you got fifth in the world it's
not that bad you're the youngest pro on
the circuit I said you know what that's
cool did you say that but I don't I'm
very stubborn and I want to train so
hard that I'm trying to make a
compelling argument with God in the
universe that even if he says no he's
going to be like well I got to give it
to him because he's just too damn
stubborn
I love that so thank you I just would
not take no for an answer I was like I'm
just no I don't care like like you say
there's certain things you can't control
I get it but I'm like I'm gonna try to
fight this thing and then xx ten comes
I'm standing up on stage with Jay Cutler
he had one for mr. Olympia titles he was
going for number three at the time and
no number four yeah number four this was
his first one then he was going for and
the announcers name is Bob Chicka row
and he always likes to draft like to
stall to create suspense for you guys so
he says like the last the next name I
read is gonna be your 2010 mr. Olympia
champion now get this I had just
previously got second place at the
Arnold Schwarzenegger classic that same
year so 2009 I got fifth came back six
months later got second thinking I'm
back in it I'm about to go do this got
new sponsors got some extra money in my
pocket I'm motivated I'm ready to kick
some ass I'm doing promos I'm telling
everybody I'm coming for you I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna do that I froze up so
anything like what do you mean froze up
like you've already did your posing like
they're just waiting for the results
froze up tell you what happened so they
announced the main they say Jay Cutler
and everybody's like hey and he and I
are friends at time and I'm happy for
him in this net I go home
I watched the video and I'm analyzing so
for me when it comes to body butter I
look at every little thing but I'm
looking at behavior so I said you are
the biggest and I'm sorry excuse my
language you're the biggest [ __ ] [ __ ]
ever Phil and one of my friends heard me
say like right off that man like what
the hell was wrong with you I said watch
this video he goes what I said you're
not seeing what I'm seeing I exhaled
they announced a colors name and I go
why did I exhale guys because I was
happy that I got second place because
you know what they do a second place
your [ __ ] um one feel I had you went in
everybody loves the underdog now
everybody roots for the underdog the
underdog is safe very interesting
he's safe Phil you just got second place
at the Arnold Classic you were robbed
there too oh you just came back from
placing fifth the year prior oh yeah I
had you know what Phil I I had you win
and man like I'm friends with Jay man
but I had you win and that's what and
you know what that does oh yeah yeah I
should have won I should have won I
didn't deserve to win because I didn't
own them but I sure as hell went in
front of those reporters man prior to
the show I'm here to win I'm here to do
this but in wood it was time to own it i
punked out so that following year I said
I'm not gonna do any promos nothing
until I own it until I own it and that
meant I don't have to talk about this I
don't have to tell people what I'm doing
I don't have to talk about what I'm
doing tomorrow and this and that and
screaming it from the mountaintops and
doing these Instagram videos on Facebook
and this and I don't have to tell you
[ __ ] I have to look in that mirror and I
have to say it to myself one damn time
and look at myself and be like man you
ain't ready or are you ready really okay
go do it so then when I won the Olympia
in 2011 it's a different type of exhale
you close your eyes and then for some
reason my life flashed before my eyes
it went all the way back to when I was a
kid like your kids like that size all
the way to the current time in 2011 but
it would it showed every defining moment
of my life every why in the road every
time where I was
I mean I'm talking about like my
birthday is a week before Christmas I
get screwed every year I grew up in the
inner city of Seattle
I remember being about your kids age
your oldest kids age coming home house
completely ransacked no Christmas no
nothing someone robbed us cops in the
house I'm just like okay no big deal I
guess I mean I don't know what it feels
like to really have anything anyway we
didn't have a lot but okay
stuff like that - watching my first high
school dance
one of my friends brothers got shot in
the face six times ten feet away from me
- winning state and basketball - getting
my degree - all these other things right
all these decisions and then it was just
like and that's when the tears come
because you're like you know what all
those little things got me here from the
heartbreak to the to the lies to the to
the deceit from others from the mistakes
I made to this and that got me here like
you just said I'm a basketball player
right back then but it got me here you
damn right I'm happy so
it was on when you talk about what kept
me going that moment right there was
like it's worth it no one else knows
what that feels like in this sport
because I was the 13th mr. Olympia
champion
so imagine only 13 people climb that
mountain so to answer the question how
did I keep it going I'm a nerd I like
video games I like the video game Mortal
Kombat for some reason okay obviously
for the fatalities I get it but so if
you ever play the game you start here
and there's like a totem pole of app
competitors people you characters you
got a beat and that's what I started
doing I was like it's not about the
competition anymore it's about who won
mr. Olympia one time Dexter Jackson
Chris Dickerson you know okay who won at
two times who won it three times who won
at four five six seven and eight is the
final level so each year I was like okay
I got to I got three I'm Tyra Sergio I
got four I'm tied with J pissed him off
okay to the point where we barely even
talk anymore okay it happens to 5 to 6
which is Dorian Yates and then I said
you know there's another perch up there
with this guy named the Austrian oak
Arnold Schwarzenegger I'm gonna see you
up there
so I remember the year I was getting
ready for in 2017 I said to Arnold at
his show came by my booth and he said
how long and I said um you know I got
something to tell you and he and I have
a very interesting relationship we don't
really we don't talk it's more like have
you ever met someone and I'm sure Pat
you have definitely met someone who
isn't really your enemy maybe your peer
but you can like stand in the same room
shake their hand not say one freaking
word but have a long conversation
it's like the movie Sherlock Holmes with
Robert Downey jr. before he like punches
the guy or whatever he's having a
conversation of what he's gonna do the
woman then that guy says the same thing
back it's more like harder than ice
shaking hands hey Phil hey how you doing
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you this
year and I'm gonna be way better than
you no you're not you little [ __ ] like
you don't matter you know so I saw it I
thought you know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna pay homage to a legend and I'm
gonna remind him because in this day and
age young people don't do that they
forget where they come from and they
don't show respect so it's one thing to
be very competitive but you gotta show
respect so what I did was I said you
know obviously I'm at your show
exhibiting for my company but I just
want to tell you would be an honor to be
tied with you for seven you know what
I'm gonna be training my ass off to make
sure that happens so he acknowledged see
and he looked at me and he and I'm there
like I said we have a very interesting
relationship but he looked at me and he
knew that I wasn't messing around it
wasn't just a rah-rah speech it wasn't
just cuz we've all done that [ __ ] he
stands back hugs me well and grabs me
and says and he can't really say you're
gonna do it because Dexter Jackson is
standing right next to me who's who's at
one time mr. Olympia so he doesn't want
to make him feel bad but he says like
the nod like yeah and stuff like that
those type of moments you know I always
keep with me and say you know what feel
like if you need some validation I mean
here it is but you don't have to
continue to seek you from others okay
sometimes I think what happens a lot of
the time is there's some people that
I've met in here they're talking about
their goals and aspirations for health
and wellness you know the first thing I
told them is stop posting all your
pictures on Instagram try your hardest
to just keep some of that to yourself
because you don't need validation from
these strangers because like you said up
here the white lies are gonna be there
they're gonna tell you how great you are
cuz I don't want to hurt your feelings
your friends like a family but your
loved ones they don't want to say man
you fat you this and that I get you got
a little love handle here you ain't yeah
you look in you ain't got no calves it
looks like you're riding a chicken like
I mean all kind of stuff you ever think
about riding the chicken like the
chicken jockey yeah okay anyway but this
is what it really takes to be a champion
is that you really have to dissect
everything every data point that Patrick
is talking about of like business I have
to do that with the amount of sleep I
get which isn't much how much water I
drink per hour the meals that I have to
prepare by the I actually had to switch
to the metric system because I'm like
you know what like this doesn't make
this ounce of stuff that makes no sense
to me anymore
so how many grams of protein carbs fats
like all your macros like everything has
to be portioned out correctly every
picture that I have I probably have two
terabytes worth of photographs and
videos that no one has ever seen because
it's not for you it's for me it's my
systems my strategies my protocols like
and then I probably will write a book
one day but I had to do all these things
to understand my process so long it's
over 80 2002 I made sure that I was
taking a picture every week front back
side to side trying to hit these poses
whatever then started critiquing myself
started flipping through the magazine
saying you know what all right I need to
do better how about I print these
pictures out take a sharpie and start
drawing what I want my body build look
like then referencing the magazine who's
got the better shoulders okay camera the
roni better shoulders okay let me do
that who's got great at Sean ray he's
got big back dooring aids ronnie coleman
legs
Tom Platts posing Arnold
okay let me combine all this stuff work
for me but let me do this because every
year your body changes putty is very
dynamic it's not static that's why we
see all these different diets and stuff
running around so that's we had to be a
student of yourself but what's been
interesting about this journey is that I
can be honest here mean when in the
Olympia was not as hard as people think
it was to deal with the outside world
the things like life things like you
talked about my father passing stuff
like that divorce I've been divorced
I've had a company before totally got
robbed millions of dollars public
scrutiny this man being misunderstood
and unlike you most of you I'm on social
media and I get hammered because we like
to pull our athletes down we liked and
you know it's funny and in bodybuilding
if you post up a picture of your body
you have to expect someone to like it
and not to like it it's just whatever
they like they're not the judge but
every day constant I can't even exhale
up here and like slouch because someone
could take a picture hmm post it yeah
see he looks like [ __ ] right here I know
he's wearing street clothes mist net but
like you could tell like he's not even
ready to win the in the don't wear in
freakin clothes right now but this is
everyday so imagine like when you're at
work it would be like Pat and another
analyst right here all the time all the
time every day all day every day all day
but you know what's cool is that I
signed up for it and I understand it's a
game and I [ __ ] love it I love it
I love it I gotta say fellas the easiest
guy to interview I asked one question
you went for 30 minutes very easy so
give it up Philly
[Applause]